I was told that when you start a compost
tea it might be an idea is sort of
inoculation with some soil bacteria
maybe yeah had a little bit of fauna or
absolutely you can get some get and
steal some from your neighbor get some
from next door ask ask for some it
really helps and the more the more you
can and if you keep some back from a
previous heat and put it through you can
even make a compost extract get some of
your compost put it in water bucket of
water stir it around and you can you can
make composite ears well you can bubble
air through it add some molasses and
some seaweed extract and you can
multiply up those bacteria and not and
funky and different microorganisms and
then you can water them back either in
your compost or on your garden where
they're real really the whole benefit of
making compost is to put those
microorganisms into your soil because
that's what's making the plants grow
it's the microorganisms they're helping
to convert the nitrogen and carbon and
all the elements into food that the
plants can assimilate and that's all
happening in the soil if you think of
that you know a billion organisms in a
gram of soil and how they multiply in a
compost heap it will double every hour
in a compost heap with the right amount
of air and water and warm they're
doubling every hour and that's what's
giving these huge temperature rises 60
70 degrees incredible process really and
all you know unsung workers we maligned
these poor bacteria tried killer mom ads
on the telly don't we kill them off I
say let them live but it's the same
principle whether you're doing it in a
Dalek bin or in the council great big
composting facilities have exactly the
same concerns you know moisture airflow
particle size how big the things that
chopped tart you know it's exactly the
same and how would you actually know
that you've got a finished product
that's ready to go back as a soil
improve would you save it for example
yeah you can serve it basically they had
they had a big composting Association
now the
organics what's it called the organics
recycling Association they had a whole
were three day conference and at the end
of that they concluded that if it looks
like compost smells like compost feels
like compost it probably is compost you
know because it's and actually lots lots
people who tell me that they haven't got
good compost all you have to do is get a
little sieve take a bit Civic show them
what saved and they're amazed as you
take out the lumps and bumps and sticks
do you end up with lovely compost and
all those bump all those lumps and stuff
you can get shoved back in again you
know how would you go about saving your
contrast to get a finer grain material
well I use them I use a length of
chicken wire just get a good length of
chicken wire and get a friend you stand
with a length of chicken wire your
French shovels some onto your chicken
wire and you just roll it from side to
side all the good stuff falls through
and then you can just flick your wire
onto one side and you can get through a
lot of stuff that way and keep your back
nice and straight and not get strained
if you're trend it with a little hand
sieve it does you back in and it's very
very hard work and also you've got a
coarser and get different grades can't
you over chicken wire so that works
young and how long would you say on
average I know it's down to seasonal
variation but how long would it take to
when you feel that you've been for it to
turn around it and produce a compost
product that's usable be probably about
six months six monthly starting now in
May so from sort of by September this
will be lovely stuff I should imagine
I'm gonna recommend lifting up the
composting and actually turning the
whole heat Wow often should you do so I
I don't protect I don't do that you can
buy em special tools that you stabbed
into aerate them I've not I've not used
them if you've got enough goods hard
structural material you shouldn't have
to do that if you put predominantly
paper and cardboard in yes you will have
to break it up you will have to wear
rate it but it's quite a lot of work
doing this so I'd rather do the garden
the
mess about with a tribunal make it right
in the first place and just leave it
alone the worms will do most of the work
would you suggest having a ready-made
pile of sort of dry carbon rich
materials such as wood chip or cardboard
already so you can get the mix right as
you're putting food yeah definitely
definitely that's so easy to do isn't it
just save up that stuff you can put it
in bags you put it in a in a bin next to
it and then you can just have a scoop
and put it in and add it so simple to
get that together you saw I've got a big
bay down there that's just got sawdust
in it sure I like to rot down a bit
before I use it get it slightly going
but I can use that then fantastic the
sawdust is good but don't use mdf only
use you know good clean would not any
stuff with mdf not block board not
fiberboard that kind of thing but the
chemicals in that will kill your
microorganisms unfortunately what other
types of food wastes that you really
shouldn't protect your composting well
meat and fish are going to attract flies
blow flies maggots you'll have you been
crawling with maggots if you put fresh
meat in they smell it from miles off
they'll come in rats of course well
we'll get in there you can set you bin
up on slabs concrete slabs and puts a
weld mesh or some mesh underneath it and
that way at least you can add certain
amount of cook food but even so if
you're going to add any cook food you
need to dilute it down well with fresh
green stuff make sure it's only a small
bit of the whole mix unless you use a
different system all together there are
other systems tumbling bins and so on
green cones but with this kind of system
not really such a good idea just stick
with the fresh peelings and that kind of
thing
what would happen if you've got a
buildup of flies is there any way to
reduce the build-up of light fruit flies
yeah any flies well fruit flies are
attracted by fruit obviously you can
wrap the fruit up in paper put it in
wrapped in paper you can cover it cover
it up with some finished compost or even
some soil if you have to although it's
not a great idea please lots of soiling
try and cover it up and bury it mask the
smell of the of the fruit as much as
possible I mean it's been a lot of fruit
going into this and there's hardly any
flies around it's quite amazing really
so as long as you get it composting well
or if it's very hot and it gets very hot
then the fruit flies also won't like
that
there is it okay for example to put a
caddy liner in there that would sort of
line your food waste caddy yes okay to
go in the heat that should break down in
time as long as it's biodegradable so
it's made of starch and not me not just
made of plastic has to say biodegradable
made of corn starch or potato starch
fully compostable if it's just says
degradable that's just plastic that
falls apart that's not good but i line
my caddy with paper much easier breaks
down much quicker
you